[موسيقى]
هو اول فعلا
واعظ يحظى بشعبيه تغير كان في قبل
الباقوري والباقولي تعرفوا الايام جمال
عبد الناصر من ايام الثوره كان موجود مع
رجال الثوره مع وزيرا اصبح وزيرا للاوقاف
في 52 يعني معهد الثوره على طول المهم
وكان ايضا شخصيه لها يعني سمح ولها حب
ولكن
اللي عمل النجاح الطاغي قوي ده كان شيخ
الشعراوي
[موسيقى]
كامله بعد رحيل جمال عبد الناصر سنه نهايه
سنه سبعين راحل عبد الناصر وبدا وبدا
السادات
اس قرر ان هو يضرب الشيوعيين او الافنديات
ساعات
كويس فقال لك ضربهم بايه بطيار اخر التيار
الديني
هوا مصر شويه ممكن يروح نحو هذا التيار
طلعهم عبد الناصر انت عارف كان بيدخل
بعضهم السجون كان كان في يعني ايه نوع من
التعتيم على رسائلهم وكانت ما يقولون يسخر
احيانا منهم وله وله يعني بعض خطب بيقولها
فيها سخريه سخريه منهم فالمهم
لما اخرجهم فبدات كمان بقى في دعم برساله
او باخرى من شيخ زي الشعراوي
[موسيقى]
اذا اذا الفراج هو هو الذي عرف الجمهور
بالشعراوي لانه برنامج ناجح ولا كان كل
اسبوع بيستضيف حد فالمهم لما وكان بيغير
الدعاه لكن اللي خد ثبات بناء على ايه انه
بدا يحس ان في مردود جماهيري لان البرنامج
كان توك توك شو يعني كان بيبقى كمان فيه
ناس موجودين في الاستوديو يسالوا اسئله
فلقوا ان شيخ الشعراوي كاريزماتيك